You
Hopefully they won't mind, hopefully.
Hey.
Ugh.
Stressful?
Aw.
Usually this helps out a lot of your work.
Work can be very stressful.
I'm hoping that your day gets better as we go.
Way better now, that's good.
Hugs friends, Laura?
Thank you.
Hmm.
Far from that I'm not active.
I'm currently watching an elderly dog for a friend.
Oh, I hope the dog is okay though.
I mean, it never reminds me of when I was working with dogs.
There was this really old dog that was like,
obsessed with me.
Will follow me everywhere.
Will leave me alone.
And the other ones which is lay on my lap.
Oh no, won't buggy.
Buggies are so cute.
I love them.
I like doggies a lot.
Am I easily scared?
Depends.
I think my form of fear of games is,
of like a scary game is like,
the act of being like,
realistically chased.
Sort of like, my biggest fear.
The game that made me like, drool.
When I screamed.
I think it was, um, Alien Isolation.
I don't think anyone's ever gonna give me to play that game.
What?
I don't think anyone's gonna ever give me to play that game.
Not in a million years.
Sorry, I meant to go turn on my light.
I didn't even make it past the tutorial.
I didn't even finish the tutorial.
That's how scared I was of that game.
Less than three?
That's funny.
I love you too.
Love you too.
Thank you so much for the six dollars that we won.
Thank you, thank you.
Have you ever played Resident Evil or Death Space?
I played a little bit of Death Space
and I like the Resident Evil series, so yeah.
Death Space is still kind of scary.
Death Space is kind of very scary.
Resident Evil not so much.
I don't know.
Ah, that big dog. Best toys ever.
I'm very sorry.
My condolences were lost.
My body was a good doggy.
Very good doggy.
Me?
I'm just reading, child.
Sorry.
It's very hot. You're so squishy.
Am I?
Super soft and warm.
Thank you.
I'm not discouraged, don't worry.
It might be disappointing as a whole, but don't worry.
I'll be okay.
Oh.
I just hang on in there and keep on streaming like normal.
I appreciate your concern, though.
A lot.
And I don't think I'm the best out of the Villalor girls.
I don't think I'm the best.
Um.
But I do appreciate that it's very sweet.
Thank you for the $1.00 details, Villalor.
As a Villalor.
I've been talking so much lately.
You know, like when you work out and your muscles get sore?
Oh, thank you so much.
You're so sweet.
Thank you.
Thank you for the $4.00.
Thank you, Papa.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
You know how when you exercise and you work out and your muscles get sore?
I've been talking so much that my, my neck, my actual neck is sore.
It hurts to touch.
I've been using my neck muscles.
So much now that my throat is like sore.
I don't really take any more morning pills or morning medication.
All my medication is always taken at night.
Always at night.
Speaking of which, let me turn off that alarm for today.
Sorry to do that.
Scared me.
I read that wrong.
Sorry.
I'm so glad.
I wish you good luck at a run.
I hope you have a good stream.
Oh, it's nice to you.
Thank you for stopping by.
Appreciate you.
Um, how do you came to just say hello?
Okay, um,
I bought the hoodie and joggers.
I can't wait for them.
I'm excited.
Well, thank you for buying the merch.
Alright, I hope you enjoy and feel comfy and cozy and dumb.
Appreciate you.
Thank you.
If anyone else wants merch, go ahead and just go in the description down below and you can get your merch there.
I hope you spend another great day with you, especially since I had a very bad day at work.
I'm sorry you had a really bad day at work.
I hope that you enjoy your time here and the stream and you feel much better as we play.
Thank you so much for $5 to be all for fun.
Thank you, thank you.
Because you said big yawn, I ended up yawning.
I was trying to hold it in.
Look what you did.
I need to turn this up, so give me one second.
Let me turn this up.
Alright, can you guys hear me a little better?
Is this better or worse?
Better or worse?
Or can I be a little louder?
I think it should be fine.
Right here?
Oh goodness.
Okay, I don't want to make too loud of a noise or something.
It's going to be extremely loud because small noises that I make can get really loud.
So I just want to be careful about that.
More Pog.
Pog?
Pog.
Ah.
Are you guys ready to play?
I have none, I don't really, I didn't, oh.
I mean, I don't want you guys to worry.
I don't want to, I didn't want to tell you about this.
I didn't want you guys to worry.
I sat here and I debated it in my head.
Should I tell them?
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's not bad, it's really not bad.
It's okay, it's fine.
I have like a vacuum cleaner and I was cleaning up and the vacuum pinched my finger.
It's fine.
The swelling went down a little bit.
I keep playing with my finger.
It's like a little purple on one side.
It's like purple on the part that got pinched.
Like purple and numb.
I have sensitive skin.
If I got like tapped, like that area is going to turn purple.
It's normal, it's normal, it's normal.
Do not be worried, it's fine.
I think it's fine.
I was just contemplating on whether or not my finger is okay.
She's a scared toe.
I'm not losing my toe, my toe is fine.
And I said I pinched my finger, not my toe.
Can I guess the booboo?
If she's going to kiss the booboo.
Yes, you can kiss the booboo.
Yeah, you can kiss the booboo.
No, not my precious vacuum.
It keeps my floor clean.
I might be like, I might have clutter in my room,
but I really don't like crumbs.
Crumbs annoy me.
But I don't hurt my vacuum.
I don't like, I really like to keep things tidy in a specific way.
I'm sorry, that was my OCD speaking.
I had slight panic in my brain about my vacuum being broken,
and it made me feel very sad.
No, not the vacuum, please.
No, no.
Mm-hmm.
Viking funeral for a vacuum.
Wow.
Okay, what is this?
Oh, I'm ready when I'm not.
I thought I was ready.
I'm not ready.
I'm not ready, I'm not ready, you know.
Booboo.
Where does this keep coming from?
I always delete this, and it always comes back.
That's so strange.
Mm-hmm.
It's very strange.
It's not super scuffed, what do you mean?
It's fine, we're not scuffed yet.
We're fine, we're fine.
I do not have malware issues.
I was only deleting a file on OBS that somehow keeps coming back.
It won't go away.
Leave me alone, go away.
I used to one time, leave me alone.
We're fine, we're fine.
Okay, now I turn this off.
Okay.
Oh, like this.
Oh, we got it.
Yay.
Now he's going to switch over now and prepares for the games.
Ha ha ha.
See, no scoof.
We're fine, no scoof.
No scoof, no scoof.
No, no, no.
No, no.
No, scoof.
No, no, no.
Mm-hmm.
Oh
Should I dim the lights for me for your eyes for your eyes
Like this
Like that
You like that
Yay
Justice looks fairly visible. Well, why I want to see oh
Oh
I didn't have to touch it then yeah
It's so different I look here and I can see it
I do here. I can't see it
This is barely visible for me
Am I blind?
Oh, right. I am
Oh
Hang on I'm nervous my aunt my armpits don't start sweating. I got a prep in advance
This would be fun
For me
Little okay, please just switch off the power if you see that okay
I
I'm so ready. I'm nervous. All right, let me fix some stuff in here. I want to make sure this is on
Be cool
Cool
Maybe
No
It's the game volume okay for you guys or is it too loud?
Let me turn you down you could better they don't have audio settings
Yeah, I don't see any audio settings
Sounds good
I
I'm gonna take this right now
I'm not procrastinating nice. I promise
Oh
I want you
I
Don't know this is actually my first time playing little nightmares
The first one
This is my first time playing the first top one. I'm not too sure. I don't really remember much from this game
I'm putting in eye drops
So
Okay
I
Guess okay, I'm ready. I'm ready. Okay. Let's do this
Okay
I
Yeah, I plan on playing both uh, then the little nightmares two and then the other one won't play it
So
Oh, I move is that it
Oh.
Can.
say that scared me and give me a second my chat literally my everything crashed
just now not like not like crash crash I mean just chat just a chat I can't see
it can't read what you guys are saying so I gotta pull it out there we go there
we go
I take my little cow and me take my little cow and me it's dark
am I supposed to do this so dark oh nice
how'd it go in
how you go in how you crowd oh
I'm scared
why do we even get on a boat
I broke it
getting used to the buttons is hard
we live paper
I don't know what I'm talking about.
What is that?
Ew.
No, I'm scared.
I'm so nervous. I don't even know what to say. You don't understand. I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared. I'm so nervous. Am I supposed to be back here?
Do I have to take out the lighter?
That's a wall.
No, bring that back. It's dark.
Okay, what do I do in here?
I'm really not good with puzzles. I don't think there'd be puzzles in here.
Can I push that?
Yeah, I noticed the handprint on the fridge.
Can I grab this? No, I can't grab anything.
I thought I had to push this or something, but I can't do that either.
I can't climb up here.
I think I have to be in this room.
Okay, the little thing ran over here.
Is it on here? Oh, yes.
The nose.
I can't take a win me.
I can't jump. You just hold the button and hold up.
I can't climb.
Is that a reach?
I can't reach.
I can't run. Where am I supposed to go?
No! It wouldn't let me run. I couldn't run.
This way, I think.
Climb. Climb. There you go.
Uh-oh.
I'm not scared of you.
I'm so nervous.
There's another thingy.
What is that on the door?
Isn't that eyeball?
Is this toilet?
Did you see that?
I'm not scared of you.
I can't reach that. It's too high up.
That's a timer.
Why is there kids toys?
Yeah. That's kind of scary.
I'm not scared of you.
That's nice.
Are we supposed to come back in here?
Do we have to run all the way across the room?
Like really fast?
Is there anything in the way?
I'm not scared of you.
This isn't very dangerous.
Nah.
I don't like that.
It's my lucky block.
Is it something that can hear me?
I can't take the block with me.
Can I jump and climb now?
Can I go up?
I want to help them.
I'll climb up.
With this?
I thought he was trapped.
Are they not trapped?
What's up here?
I am lucky.
I don't know which way to go.
I know me.
I'm scared.
I don't know which way to go.
We're hungry.
I know this feeling on too well.
I'm going to give it to me.
Was that bread? Why is it so squelchy?
Thank you.
What did I eat? Was that bread?
My dear mommy, you got this. I've got some free time so I'll watch you.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
Thank you for the $5 tipi.
I hope you'll join me in your free time.
It's a noose.
It's too shower.
There's so many cages.
I got to remember that you don't press space when climbing. Do not press space.
What was that?
Now what?
That noise.
Am I supposed to do something with this?
What was that?
That's a long fall.
Is that supposed to be up here?
I pressed space by accident.
Can I push this? No.
I won't get it.
What am I supposed to do here?
I climbed that.
Keep climbing.
Not then.
There's a little water here. What did this go to?
What do you pull first?
What was that?
I'm a genius.
I can't let me climb it now.
I'm stuck.
Nothing else in here?
Hey, isn't this where it was before?
Where are the children?
Oh, no.
Why is this area all of a sudden really dark and scary?
I don't like this camera angle. Why do I feel like something's going to come?
I'm stuck.
I don't know what sound came out of me.
Why is this so scary? I don't like that. It's scary.
It's so scary.
I'm stuck.
That was dark.
Oh, it's the gnomes.
I made it out.
I'm stuck.
I want to go up there. I want to know what's up there.
What's up here? Am I going to fall again?
What's in here?
Am I going to fall again?
I don't know what's in there.
Is this an entire area?
It's not open.
I can't see.
It's a floor.
If I go in there, then I can't go up the stairs.
The chair.
I want to know what's up the stairs.
What's up here?
It's a door.
What if I fall?
The stairs are evil.
Can I leave?
I'm stuck.
I want to go back.
I didn't want to go.
I shouldn't have come up here.
Am I going to fall again?
Am I going to fall?
Yeah.
Am I going to fall again?
I can't always do this key, not that we have a key.
I don't know what's that.
Am I going to fall again?
Dang, no sympathy.
What's over here?
Wait, am I going to make that?
How do I make that?
Downstairs, evil stairs.
Do I just run?
I'm doing it.
Now the game wants to start giving me advice.
How do I get in there?
What's the kid?
Is the kid alive?
They're definitely still alive, right?
How do I get in there?
What am I supposed to do?
I did it.
Why is this so loud?
How do I get in there?
Hang on, give me one second.
I need a second.
I need a second, give me a second.
How can people play that so normally, like nonchalant, like just be so unfair, I don't understand how you guys do that.
I don't understand.
I'm so sad, my mom isn't here, she's not going to be here for a couple of days again.
She's like never here, she's like never home.
She left me something and I can get something.
So give me one moment, I want to order something.
Give me a moment.
Yeah.
This heart monitor sucks for people with breasts.
Okay.
I'm doing alright.
Let's do it.
No.
Okay.
This is amazing hearing you telling me he didn't hear that.
I had to climb up there.
I have to go all the way up here.
Okay, so how do I go back up?
How do I go back up?
How do I go up there?
Did I trap myself?
Was I supposed to have put the thingy in there?
Am I trapped?
I have to go.
I passed it a few times.
Yeah.
Over here.
Alright.
Okay.
Can you like leave?
Can you leave?
Why are you breathing so hard?
Why is he breathing so hard?
Why is he still in here?
Use monkeys?
What if he turns around really fast?
Okay.
Hang on one second.
Thank you, food came. I have food now.
Usually they like call you to let you know they're there, but they didn't call me this morning.
They're their phone.
I have beef, beef, beef broccoli, and white rice.
I haven't had beef in a while.
Okay.
I'm so sorry if that hurt anyone's ears.
I hit my hand on the microphone really, really hard.
Hang on.
Okay.
I mean, like, it's so weird. There's sauce on the broccoli, but I don't taste the sauce. You know what I mean? There's sauce on the broccoli.
Am I weird?
Okay.
Maybe there's like a few pieces of broccoli in here that just don't taste good.
It's like a mix.
Maybe you're getting sick and losing your sense of taste.
I thought I hope not. If I get sick, I get sick for a really long time. I would have to take a few days off if I get really sick. If I get sick to the point I lose sense of taste.
I would have to take a few days off once like symptoms start hitting me. My immune system takes a long time to fight stuff off.
My immune system takes a long time. So I'd be sick in bed for a really long time. Sleeping. Long stop sleeping. Got a rest.
The sauce. The sauce tastes funny. It's like they changed the sauce. Like it tastes different.
I like celery too, but imagine eating something and tasting something entirely different. Just because you like that taste of the food that you usually eat doesn't mean you want to taste it in the food that you're eating right now.
What you've been is the sauce? I don't even know. Does anyone ever question or know what's in their food when they order it?
Really? So you go to a Chinese spot and you go what's in the sauce? What's in the sauce?
What is in there?
You think they'll really tell you?
A secret formula?
I want the secret formula.
A secret formula.
I think I know what it is. It's the combination of the rice and the sauce. Every time I put the rice and the sauce together and I eat it, the taste is very hard to describe.
It doesn't taste great when you combine the rice and the sauce. Usually that's never the case. I'm confused why it's so bad right now.
But the sauce with the meat and the broccoli is kind of okay, but when you combine the rice, it tastes kind of funny.
It tastes a little funny.
Yes, white rice, beef and broccoli.
Yeah, it's a soda. I only drink the ginger ale. Nope. Ginger ale.
Do you guys open your can halfway, not all the way? And then suck on it? I do that. I barely open it. I'm in my suck on it.
I do it all the time. It's fun.
But if you do that, remember to clean your can, clean the top of your can before you do that. If anyone ever gets curious to do it, wipe the top of your can.
No, I don't like this. Sorry, excuse me. I really don't like this.
That's a dub. No, thank you.
That almost made me barf.
Whatever sauce this is, the sauce ruined everything.
I have a very sensitive stomach and taste buds. So I trust my gut.
If my tongue tells me that this isn't good, I shouldn't eat it.
Even my mom, my mom and my sister and all my other siblings trust my taste buds. They used to question it.
They used to be like, oh, there's no way that every time you eat something in your tongue says it tastes bad that we shouldn't eat it.
I'm like, go ahead, eat it. Then they either get food poisoning or they like throw it up or they get really sick.
So whatever. I trust my tongue. I'm not eating that.
My body, I tried to swallow it and then my body literally made it come back up. Nope. I'm good. I'm not going to eat it.
Some of it that I already swallowed, my stomach is starting to hurt a little bit.
Alright, it's fine. It was a burp. We're okay. We're okay. It was a burp. I'm just a tiny bit nauseous. That's all.
I can eat this. I can't eat that. This is fine. But every time I eat that, it's not fine. What is that?
Yeah, the rice. The rice is just not, it's not hitting me very well. I don't want to eat that. The other stuff is fine.
But the rice was wrong with the rice. No, it's not overcooked, I don't think.
Probably old rice, maybe. Every time I try to eat the rice, I get really nauseous. It tastes strange. Really strange. I don't like it. I don't like it.
It's time for pancakes. I can't have sugar any more today. I already had pancakes earlier. Too much sugar. It's fine if I can eat some of it. It's fine as long as I eat something, right?
It should be okay. Yeah.
It wasn't burnt. It wasn't burnt. It wasn't a burnt pancake, okay? It was not burnt. It was nice pancake-y, okay? I made the pancake-y and it was good. My camera on my phone makes everything much darker. I don't know why. I can't fix it.
The pancake was literally golden with brown edges. It was golden with brown edges. It was golden and had brown edges, but the camera made the edges look black. It's not my fault.
It wasn't slimy. It was perfect. You know when you take a bite out of the edge and it goes crunch and then soft? Like the tiny, tiny little piece of the edge is crunch, crunch, crunch. And it's yummy.
Just a little toasting. Well, it was fried. It was fried. I did use quite a bit of butter. And someone said that there was garlic on top of it. Why the heck would I put garlic on top of a pancake? It was melted butter. Melted butter.
You will feel how there is melted butter.
It's like how my grandpa used to make pancakes. Really? It was good. It's a lot of butter. Butter makes the edges really crispy.
Edges of pancakes really crispy. It was super nice. It was super soft and really white on the inside. Like puffy, like puffy white.
That was a good pancake, I mean. It was just one giant pancake. Someone asked if I dusted in syrup. I didn't. The syrup just like slid off the top all around the side. So it looked like it was like sitting in syrup.
But trust it wasn't. It was just a tiny bit of syrup because I can't have too much sugar.
The more you tease, the higher the chances of me eating you instead of my pancakes. The choice is yours. Promise.
You'd be an honor. My body is ready.
Imagine. I could see it. I want to get some art done. I don't want to draw it. I want to see a professional draw it. I want to do it. I want to get a professional draw certain things.
I just need to see where, you know, where.
Oh.
Ha ha ha.
I'm excited a little bit of this, but I am nauseous and I have a high sneaking suspicion that this is going to come right back up in like a few minutes.
With the off chance that it doesn't, I eat it.
Ew.
I think this is going to make me sick. Continues eating it.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm hungry. It's better to eat it and then barf it up and let your body do the talking or eat it and chances you keep it down and then you're full. Bam, you have food in there and then the digest and you're fine.
I have nutrition. You have food in there. You don't waste it. No waste food. You don't waste it. You eat some of it.
If your body is really hungry and starving it will ignore some of the some of the bad stuff.
If it's hungry enough, don't eat it. It will take it. Take what it can get.
Yeah, it'll be fine. It's fine.
Not to stop drinking this boil milk. Only if you're absolutely starving. But I don't recommend drinking spoiled milk or dairy.
I've been drinking spoiled milk before.
Those were the days.
It was like absolutely nothing. Nothing in the fridge. I remember I hadn't eaten for days. I was so hungry. I was so hungry and my mom was out working so she was like never home and it was just me and my sibling, my younger sibling.
And I was like, oh, yeah, I am so hungry. I took the cereal. It was like really stale cereal. I had born me a bowl and the milk was like kind of like chunky.
And I sat on the floor, crouched on the floor with my sibling in front of me and we stared at the bowl and I was like, I'll eat it first if it kills me. Don't eat it.
I couldn't let my younger sibling eat it and then what if they like perish and then I didn't want to meet my mom's wrath of letting my younger sibling eat the spoiled food.
So I ate it. I ate a little bit of it and it made me so sick. I was so sick. Yeah, I saw it was spoiled. I was hungry. Excuse me.
I was starving. Yeah, me and my sibling was starving. We were hungry. We were very hungry. I felt like something stuck in my throat. Oh my god.
I hear a fine.
A yogurt with spoiled milk. That sounds gross.
I mean, I know yogurt is made out of that kind of like made out of that but don't you need like a special process to make it like like doesn't it take like a long time to make yogurt.
It doesn't like all the bad stuff kind of need to be like filtered out of it. Did your mom do all of that? It's not that hard. I guess so people make their own cheese with spoiled milk so I'm not surprised.
It still sounds gross.
My long distance family member makes their own cheese with spoiled milk. They make a mozzarella cheese for their pizza.
Well, I guess it's not spoiled milk. I guess it's normal milk before it spoils and they just warm it up and then make cheese with the milk. I don't think it's really spoiled though.
Mozzarella cheese with mozzarella cheese. Yeah, soon to be spoiled. I mean homemade cheese is how you make cheese instead of having to go all the way out to go buy cheese you can make just make your own cheese.
I remember making ice cream in school but you don't use spoiled milk to make ice cream. No more, no more, no more normal milk.
I have another minute after that story.
I mean you could but why? It would murder you. You know.
You know sherbet ice cream? You know I can't eat that. I can't have sherbet ice cream.
I will absolutely destroy my stomach beyond what anything else I can eat. I don't know. I think it's the sugar because sherbet ice cream does have a ton of sugar.
I think it's the sugar but I cannot have sherbet. I used to eat so much of it. I think I like gained that thing. I used to eat so much sherbet ice cream in the past when I was younger. I used to eat so much of it.
And then after a little while like years later all of a sudden every time I ate it I was in excruciating pain. I was in so much pain. It was so bad.
And then I would test it. I would I bought another one again. Like not recently but like a few years ago I bought one and I was like I'm gonna test it and only eat a tiny bit. Just two spoonfuls.
My stomach. That was it. I couldn't eat it. It's impossible. It's absolutely impossible.
Well because my doctor said the only way to find out if I have an actual intolerance the stuff is to eat them. So I was testing it by eating it.
My doctor was like well the only way to know is to eat it. And I was like okay. And I ate it. And then I was like.
Yeah I actually have the mess around to find out.
That was years ago when I had the huge humongous stomach aches. Then I stopped eating it for a couple of years. And then my doctor was like and then I got a new doctor and my doctor was like what can you not eat.
And I said sherbet ice cream. It makes my stomach hurt. And I was like are you sure. And I was like well like what if it doesn't hurt now. And I was like I don't know.
I haven't eaten it since then because it made my stomach hurt. And I was like well the only way you can know is to eat it. And I was like okay.
I guess I'll taste it again. And yes. And I ate it again. I had to do the same thing with cheese and everything else. They made me eat it again.
And I went back in and they were like so what can you not eat. And I was like oh yeah for sure sherbet ice cream can't eat that.
Was that loud. I was drinking soda. Was that loud. I really thought I turned that off. I guess I didn't. I think I forgot to turn it off.
No.
Help me. Help me.
Help me.
Was it realistic that you thought it was real.
I can't do this anymore.
Help me.
I can't take it.
oh shit I drilled oh man
yeah yeah yeah would you think you're acting like a zombie
I'm a zombie
I love you zombie
I don't know why I think that you like that I at first I thought the YouTube emotes were
a little silly looking but they're growing on me I don't know why they're really growing
on me. I think I really like some of these YouTube emotes. I think they're great.
So we stop procrastinating. I don't like that one. I don't I don't like that one. No that one I
don't like it. So what about this one? No, I don't like that one. I don't like it.
The game scared you so far. What do you think? What do you think?
I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it.
I didn't mean to do that. I pressed the wrong button. I pressed the wrong button. I pressed the wrong button.
I don't like it. I don't like it.
I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it.
I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it.
I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it.
I can't see. This is on my way. I have to move it. You gotta go up there. On my way. I'm scared.
I'm scared.
What's wrong?
No. No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
What are you supposed to do there?
Hide?
What? What am I supposed to do? Just run? I don't know. I don't know what am I supposed to do? I kept running last time. He still got me.
I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it.
I don't like it. I don't like it.
Sonic X.
What the heck am I supposed to do up here?
What the heck am I supposed to do?
What the heck am I supposed to do here?
Why?
I don't know what I'm supposed to do here.
Oh. Oh!
I just have this line.
Stop tripping.
What the heck am I supposed to do here?
What the heck am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do here?
What the heck am I supposed to do here?
Oh.
I can try and do tingles but I'm not too sure.
I'm not at all like super like extreme knowledgeable of all the like every single trigger.
So I've been looking up some stuff but I don't have the I don't have a lot of stuff to do this.
The triggers but eventually I will get them and then I can do all the stuff.
I have more triggers for you guys and I was more than just happy to use my voice and my praises and stuff.
But since I can't really do all the extra sounds and stuff I got to be careful.
So I need a little extra more other other stuff.
I can still do praises.
I can still do requests.
I can still say stuff.
But I have to be careful with noises.
Scalp scratches.
You have to also be careful with the breathing as well.
I hate that too.
I know we had a spooky time and I can't wait for more.
Thanks for making feel better today.
Love you lots.
Spooky time was fun.
Thank you.
I'm so happy that you feel even better today.
I hope I'm glad that those will help you.
Thank you so much for the $5 to be all for fun.
Thank you.
Wow.
Yum yum.
I thought you were the green goat.
I'm a thawna store now.
Gow.
Wait, or is that like a lion?
Yeah.
I'm going to eat you.
I'm going to turn massively big.
Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw!
Woaw...
I
Pick someone up
Stream looking forward for tomorrow's ASMR
Thank you for $5 to be
Oh
Thanks everyone for stopping by today's stream by the way if you have
to live early. I appreciate y'all. Thank y'all for being here and being amazing.
Come on again. Come on again. Come on again. Come on again. Come on again. Come on again. Come on again.
Waiting hard outside. There may be one being made in the future yes. We just have to be very patient
for it. For it to come. But be patient maybe there'll be one in the future.
Just look forward to the future.
Oh, eb eb necessitating me. I did have somewhat of a kind of good sleep. Not really.
I like only slept for like three hours. But I did sleep throughout the rest of the day.
Like I woke after I went to sleep. I was asleep for like three hours. I knocked out and I was like
and then I like woke up and then I went and then I fell back asleep like hours later. I ate
like food. I made pancake. After the pancake, I took a nap. After the pancake, I went to sleep
for a few hours now.
I resty. Don't worry.
I want I want an emote where I'm wearing a dino a dino onesie.
With my horns sticking out of the onesie is top of the onesie.
I don't want a dino onesie.
She be roasted your pancake. My pancake was fine.
Me and she be gone throw hands. We're gonna fight.
And I'm gonna stuff my pancake down her mouth and make her eat it. And then so
so understand the wonders of my pancakes. Okay, I make the best pancakes.
The lighting just messed it up. I like have like no light in my kitchen.
It's very dumb. You can barely see. The pancake was good. It wasn't bad.
Mmmm.
Do you want a plushie of me to huggy?
I want a plushie.
I will collect all the girls plushies.
I think plushies are so cute.
I'm out of the whole collection.
I want the whole collection.
I hate you.
I want a plushie.
A plushie of me sounds so cool.
So awesome.
We should make a plushie with all of us with this face.
The pancake was really good.
It was amazing.
Hey, that's mean.
Why do you say that?
That's mean.
I don't need classes to make pancake.
My pancake was good.
It was a good pancake.
Stop bullying me for my pancakes, OK?
Stop bullying me.
My pancake was good.
One day, I want to make you eat it.
And you're going to like my pancake.
You hear me?
You're going to like it.
You're going to enjoy it.
Oh, I'm going to make you eat it.
I'm cakey.
Work feed.
Or you're going to have another taste of my other cake.
I'm going to make you eat it.
It's a big stretch.
And fireman's a hit.
Oh, it's only 12.
Not that late.
I thought it was like super late.
Who's live right now?
Let me check you.
Marseille and Srony is live.
Marseille and Srony.
Srony, Srony.
Hang on a minute, OK?
Marseille and Srony.
She's still alive?
Like real?
Like real, real?
Like you're not lying?
Real, real?
She's still alive?
Marseille?
You lied to me.
You lied to her.
She is not lying.
She was live.
Yeah, let me see, oh yeah, my meds, I forgot about that.
Actually forgot, completely forgot about that, thank you!
Turn it off, I turned it off immediately.
Good night, bye bye, thank you for stopping by, bye bye, that sweet dream is my little
bleeding heart.
I'm gonna read mercy, mercy, first round me, mercy, first round me, mercy, first round me.
What the heck, where did my chagol, oh there you guys are, hi chat, I'll see you guys tomorrow,
so if you guys haven't already done so, please remember to like and subscribe and leave a
comment section and ring the little bell, thank you so much for being here for today
and part of today's stream, it was very fun, yeah, hope you're ready for tomorrow's ASMR
stream and remember to check out the description for merch and to patreon and so on and so forth,
so for today's comment, please leave a comment saying, I like dino's, I like dino nuggies,
I like dino nuggies in the comments section, dino nuggies, dino nuggies, dino nuggies,
dino nuggies, dino nuggies, dino nuggies, bye bye, bye bye, my precious sweet,
bleeding heart, have a good night's sleep, good night's sleep, good night, good night,
my precious bleeding heart, good night,
my precious bleeding heart, good night's sleep, good night's sleep, good night's sleep,
good night's sleep, good night's sleep, good night's sleep, good night's sleep,
good night's sleep, good night's sleep, good night's sleep,